(computer clicking)
(techno music)
- I'm the driven one.
- And I'm trying to have a life.
Like I don't want
something in my home
that's like, ugly, because--
- You wouldn't buy an ugly sofa.
- And like you wouldn't
talk to an ugly person.
- You look ridiculous right now.
- [Liz B.] Stop it, Liz.
- I--
- You know when I, like,
(squeals)
(alters voice to
be unintelligible)
- What? (squeaks)
Because you're like (bleep)
five years old and like--
- You're like (bleep)
eight years old--
- Like, I'm (mumbles)
years old and I know
what to do so thank you,
you know what I mean?
It's like, just go to bed.
I really do hate
water, like, I hate it.
- Apparently they
neglected to refrigerate
the yogurt drinks.
Everyone got sick, it's
been all over the Internet.
(gasps)
- Those cupcakes look amazing.
- Oh, the cupcakes.
- [Liz B.] They're
wearing little bikinis.
- This is not what I envisioned.
- Publizity.
- It's based off our name.
(techno music)